[Musique]
cette pétition avait pour but en effet
de d'expliquer que peut-être le masque
huit heures par jour pour nos enfants
c'était quand même est disproportionné
par rapport à aux virus et moi j'ai du
mal à comprendre bon protège qui de quoi
comme c'est très confus et que l'on nous
a dit que les enfants n'étaient pas
forcément porteur donc ça veut dire quoi
alors on porte le masque pour se
protéger des autres enfants pour
protéger le professeur mais qui sur une
estrade au loin
d'abord parce que donc c'est en effet un
inconfort donc il faut il faut quand
même gérer ça en plus des apprentissages
vous apprenez mais vous voyez pas votre
les paroles de notre interlocuteur mais
je pense aussi qu'il imprime de
relations sociales parce que c'est avec
son visage qu'on rencontre l'autre avec
son sourire avec son expression avec ses
émotions enfin et les enfants c'est
vraiment les adolescents surtout c'est
aussi enfin les amitiés l'orage c'est
presque le plus important et c'est
difficile moi je m'étais dit à l'air
libre dans la cour de récré on peut
peut-être avoir ce temps de respiration
oui en effet quand ils sont à distance
les uns des autres
peut-être avoir des temps où la ménage
dans la journée et aussi qu'on sache
jusqu'à quand parce qu'on va passer
habitué à vivre est une société masqué
je nie pas qu'il ya un virus et qu' il
faut faire attention peut-être le
gouvernement s'est dit ben may ce que
tout le monde comme ça voilà mes mais il
ya peut-être des aménagements possibles
et une réflexion à faire sur enfin voilà
sur nos enfants parce que c'est la
société de demain et on va faire une
société de deux dents d'adulte qui sont
qui sont anxieux dépressifs
il faut réfléchir à ça aussi aux
conséquences et il me semble qu'elles
elles peuvent être plus dramatique s'ils
voulaient que ce qu'on est censé éviter
aujourd'hui